يوم 11 يناير اللي فات اعلان الاني اكبر
شركه لشحن الحاويات في العالم الشركه
الدنماركيه العملاقه ميرسك ان سفنها اللي
بتربط بين استراليا ونيوزيلندا من جهه
ومدينتي فيلاديلفيا وتشارلز على الساحل
الشرقي للولايات المتحده من جهه ثانيه
واللي مفروض في الطبيعي انها بتمر من قناه
بانما هتتوقف عن استخدام القناه وهتضرب
تستخدم استراتيجيه الجسر البري باستخدام
الموانئ في بانما وخط السكك الحديديه
لخدمه الحاويات يعني ايه الكلام ده يا
اخوانا وليه الكلام ده خطير سفن ميرسك
اللي بتنقل البضايع بين استراليا
ونيوزيلاندا ومدن الشرق الامريكيه المفروض
انها بتعدي من قناه بانما ولكن بسبب
انخفاض منسوب الميه في القناه اضطرت هيئه
القناه انها تقلل عدد السفن اللي بتعدي
وتقلل الحموله بتاعتها فهنا سفن ميرسك مش
عارفه تعدي فالشركه لجات لاستخدام الجسر
الارضي وبالتالي السفن اللي محمله بضاعه
جايه من استراليا ورايحه شرق امريكا
امريكا اول ما توصل لغرب بانما وبدل ما
تدخل القناه هتفضي البضاعه في ميناء
بالبوا على جانب المحيط الهادي بعد كده
الحاويات هتتحمل على خط سكك حديديه ماشي
بطول القناه لمسافه 80 م م تقريبا من غرب
بنمل شرقها لحد ما يتم انزال الحاويات مره
ثانيه في ميناء مانزانيلو على جانب المحيط
الاطلسي شرق بانما وهناك سفن ميرسك هتاخد
الحاويات وتبحر لشرق امريكا طبعا عن السفن
بتنزل حاويات وترجع محمله بحاويات ثانيه
وهكذا من المينائي الواقعين شرق وغرب
بانما وخط السكك الحديديه بينقل الحاويات
في الاتجاهين وخط السكك الحديديه ده
بالمناسبه تابع لشركه قناه بنمل السكك
الحديديه واللي بيملكه بشكل مشترك شركه
السكك الحديديه الكنديه بسيفك كانساس سيتي
وشركه مي جاك برودكتس الامريكيه وهنا في
شويه اسئله مهمه جدا ايه اللي بيحصل
بالظبط في واحد من اهم الممرات الملاحيه
في العالم والمنافس الاكبر لقناه السويس
المصريه وليه شركات الشحن جابت اخرها من
قناه بانما وبدات تحول مسار سفنها وازاي
البنامين بيواجهوا كارثه ما كانتش لا على
البال ولا على الخاطر وازاي الكارثه دي
هتاثر على التجاره العالميه وهل قناه
السويس هتقدر تستفيد من الوضع الحرج لقناه
بانما ده وازاي قناه بانما اللي هي اعجوبه
هندسيه بشريه بتشتغل اصلا وازاي البنامين
ومعاهم الامر كان بيفكروا في حلول للكارثه
دي كل ده واكتر هنجاوب عليه في حلقه
النهارده المهمه جدا جدا واللي كتير منكم
طلبها مننا فلازم تشوفوها انا اشرف
ابراهيم والمخبر
الاقتصادي حلقه دي برعايه شركه ايفي تريد
وهي شركه ماليه مرخصه في جزر القمر ولها
تواجد كبير في اسواق الخليج العربي ايفي
تريد بيقدموا خدمه خدمه الدعم على مدار ال
24 ساعه وبيساعده في اداره الحسابات
واستغلال الفرص الاستثماريه وعندهم برنامج
ولاء لجمع النقاط واللي يمكن استبدالها
بعروض ومكافات نقديه والحقيقه بيعجبني
اهتمامهم بالتعليم لهم منصه تعليميه فيها
دورات مجانيه لتعلم مهارات التداول فتقدر
من خلال دوراتهم المجانيه تتعرف اكت عن
السوق ده وتفهم الفرص والمخاطر اللي فيه
تلاقوا رابط لهم تحت الفيديو ولو سجلت منه
هتحصل على مكافاه بتوصل ل 100% في سنه
1869 تم الانتهاء من حفر قناه السويس
وافتتاحها رسميا بعد 10 سنين من الحفر تحت
اشراف المهندس الفرنسي فرديناند ديليسيبس
بعدها ب 11 سنه وتحديدا سنه
1880 ديليسيبس طار على بانما علشان يبدا
يحفر قناه بانما بدات اعمال الحفر على
مدار تسع سنين ومات خلال الفتره دي اكثر
من 200000 عامل بسبب الملاريا والحمه
الصفراء وبعض الامراض الاستوائيه بتاع
انيه وفشلت محاوله ديليسيبس والفرنسيين في
حفر القناه ورغم الانتكاسات دي فضل
الامريكيين في عهد الرئيس الامريكي ثيودور
روزفيلد مهتمين جدا بحفر القناه لشحن
البضايع بسرعه وبتكلفه زهيده بين سواحل
المحيط الاطلسي والمحيط الهادي لحد ما
نزلوا بناما سنه 1903 وبداوا بعدها اعمال
حفر القناه وبتكلفه وصلت وقتها ل 375
مليون دولار ومقتل
5609 شخص تمل بناء القناه وبكده اتفتح
المحيط الهادئ على المحيط الاطلسي وتم
افتتاح القناه رسميا في 15 اغسطس سنه
1914 بعد ما ابحرت اول سفينه تجاريه وهي
سفينه اس اس انكون الامريكيه افتتاح
القناه اختصر المسافه بين شرق وغرب
الولايات المتحده لانه ربط المحيطين
الهادي والاطلسي ببعض وده عمل ثوره في
الشحن العالمي للي ما يعرفش من حضراتكم
قبل حفر قناه بانما كانت السفن بتضطر
بتسافر حوالين الطرف الجنوبي لامريكا
الجنوبيه عند منطقه كيب هورن عند جزيره
هورن اقصى جنوب تشيلي البحر في المنطقه دي
يا اخوانا يعتبر من اسوا الاماكن للابحار
في العالم بحر عاصف جدا وكان بمثابه مقبره
حقيقيه للسفن لعده قرون هناك مات الاف
البحاره وفقد عدد لا يحصى من السفن
وبالتالي قناه بانما اختصرت كل ده واثرت
الرحله باكثر من 13000 كيلو و فرت وقت
وفلوس وارواح على مدار قرن تقريبا فضلت
قناه بانما شغاله لحد سنه 2016 بشكل عادي
جدا ولكن كانت قادره على استيعاب السفن
الاصغر اللي بتشيل لحد 5000 حاويه مكافئه
بس والحاويات المكافئه تيو هي الحاويات
اللي طولها 20 قدم وبالتالي الاقفال اللي
بتدخل وتخرج السفن من القناه ما كانتش
بتتس الا لسفينه عرضها
32.3 متر بس ومع اهميه وحيويه الممر
الملاحي ده وزياده حركه الشحن العالمي
والمنافسه الشرسه مع قناه السويس قررت
هيئه قناه بانما اضافه المزيد من الفتحات
الاوسع للقناه وانفقوا 5.3 مليار دولار
لبناء الاقفال الجديده اللي تقدر تستوعب
سفن اكبر بيوصل حجمها ل 15000 حاويه
مكافاه وعرض السفينه بيوصل ل 49 متر وقتها
هيئه قناه بانما كانت بتتفاعل انه بعد
التوسعه دي هيقدروا يج ب من اربع لخمس
رحلات اسبوعيه من قناه السويس المهم
التوسعه الضخمه دي دخلت الخدمه على
مرحلتين في 2016 و208 من وقتها وقناه
بانما قدرت تجذب عدد اكبر من اسطول الشحن
العالمي وسفن اكبر حجما لدرجه ان القناه
بيعدي منها بضايع ب 270 مليار دولار في
السنه
وبتستحمي حركه الحاويات في الولايات
المتحده لوحدها بس كل ده طبعا انعكس على
ايرادات القناه اللي بيعتمد عليها اقتصاد
بنما بشكل كبير واللي وصلت في 2022 ل 4.3
مليار دولار بيمثلوا
6.6% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي اللي بن
مع لكن التوسعه دي سهمت في حدوث الكارثه
اللي بتمر بها قناه بانما بقى ها كا شهر
وحتت فاقم في المستقبل وبعد شويه هنعرف
ازاي ده حصل ولكن قبلها محتاجين نعرف
القناه دي شغاله ازاي اصلا لان ده مهم
لفهم اللي بيحصل صل هناك زي ما قلت لكم
قبل كده في حلقه تاثير هجمات الحوثيين على
السفن التجاريه في البحر الاحمر واللي ما
شافهاش من حضراتكم لازم يشوفها من هنا ان
في فرق بين قناه السويس وقناه بانما في
مستوى الميه في القناتين قناه السويس هي
قناه افقيه ميه البحر بتتدفع فيها بشكل
طبيعي على الجانبين سواء من ناحيه البحر
الاحمر او المتوسط السفن بتدخل وتخرج من
القناه بشكل سلس وطبيعي عبر الممر المائي
المسطح ولكن ده مش حاصل في قناه بانما
وهقول لكم ازاي الفكره باختصار شديد ان
السفن علشان تمر من قناه بانما لازم تترفع
عن سطح البحر حوالي 26 متر وبعد كده تدخل
بحيره اصطناعيه ضخمه وهي بحيره جاتون تمشي
فيها لحد ما توصل للناحيه الثانيه وبعدها
هيتم انزال السفن مره ثانيه لمستوى سطح
البحر طب السفن بتترفع وتنزل على طرفي
القناه ازاي من خلال نظام الاقفال او اله
وسه مفردها هويس تعالوا نشوف الاقفال دي
بتشتغل ازاي لنفترض ان في سفينه سائبه
محمله فول صويا من شرق الولايات المتحده
ورايح الصين السفينه هتدخل قناه بانما من
ناحيه المحيط الاطلسي هتعدي من ثلاث اقفال
علشان تترفع 2 متر عن سطح مياه المحيط طب
ازاي هيتم سحب السفينه للهويس او القفل
الاول من خلال قطارات جر موجوده على جانبي
القفل بعدها هتتقفل بوابه المصب وهيت فح
ميه من اعلى البحيره علشان يتملي الهويس
وبالتالي السفينه هتط فوا بارتفاع حوالي
8.5 متر ولما الميه تتساوى بمستوى القفل
الثاني هيسحب السفينه للقفل او الهويس
الثاني وهيقفل البوابات بعدها هيفتحوا
الميه علشان تملى الهويس الثاني فالسفينة
فالسفينة
خلى العالم يطلق على نظام الاقفال ده ان
واحد من اهم العجائب الهندسيه اللي صنعها
الانسان في العصر الحديس وزي ما حضراتكم
لاحظتوا فمرور السفن معتمد على مياه
مصدرها بحيرات مياه زبه مقام عليها سدود
علشان تجمع الميه وتبدا تنزلها في احواض
الاقفال دي طب ده كلام جميل فين المشكله
بقى زي ما قلنا القناه محتاجه للمياه
الزبه في بحيره جاتون علشان تشغل الاقفال
اللي بترفع السفن علشان تقدر تدخل وتخرج
من القناه كل سفينه علشان تعبر من قناه
بانما محتاجه حوالي 200 مليون لتر ميه في
المتوسط وده بيعادل ملء 80 حوض سباحه
اوليمبي لما الاقفال بتتملي بالميه بتختلف
المياه المالحه بالمياه العزبه وبالتالي
الميه العزبه اللي جايه من البحيرات بيتم
تصريفها في المحيط علشان باقي الميه ما
تبقاش ملحه علشان كده بيتم فقد كميات
مهوله من الميه مع مرور كل سفينه والقناه
بي عدي منها في الايام العاديه من 36 ل 38
سفينه في اليوم فحضرت متخيلين كميه الميه
اللي القناه محتاجاها علشان تشغل الاقفال
بتاعتها بشكل يومي واللي بيتم تصريف
معظمها في المحيط اقفال قناه بانما معتمده
بشكل اساسي على بحيرتين بحيره جاتون ودي
مساحتها 425 م مربع وبحيره مادن او
الاخويلا ومساحتها حوالي 51 م مربع
والبحرين هم اكبر مصدر للمياه الصالحه
للشرب في بانما وبيعتمد عليها في الشرب نص
السكان البالغ عددهم 4.3 مليون نسمه ده
غير ان المجتمعات الزراعيه المحليه
بيعتمدوا عليهم في الزراعه برده علشان كده
كنت بقول لكم من شويه ما ينفعش ميه المحيط
المالحه تختلط بميه البحيرات العزبه علشان
كده قناه بانما بتصرف معظم الميه في
المحيط هنا حد مصحصح معايا هيسال سؤال
لوبي هو ايه اللي استجد يعني ما القناه
شغاله بقى لها اكث من 100 سنه الفكره هنا
ان البحيرات الاصطناعيه بتعتمد على هطول
الامطار موسم الامطار اللي بيبدا في بانما
عاده من اواخر شهر ابريل لحد شهر نوفمبر
كل سنه بيعيد ملء البحيرات دي وعلى راسهم
طبعا اكبر بحيره وهي جاتو واللي بدورهم
بيغزو الاقفال بتاعه القناه ولكن اللي حصل
بقى في
2023 ولسه مستمر ومتوقع انه هيكمل معانا
ان بانما في شهر اكتوبر اللي فات ضربها
اكبر موجه جفاف ما حصلتش من سنه
1950 في شهر اكتوبر ده حصل هطول للامطار
اقل بنسبه 41% من المتوسط متوقع ان انخفاض
هطول الامطار ده يستمر لحد موسم الامطار
اواخر شهر ابريل الجاي علشان كده دلوقتي
بنشوف الخزان الرئيسي لقناه بانما وهي
بحيره جاتون الميه بتنخ فض فيها لمستويات
غير مسبوقه في الوقت ده من السنه ومتوقع
ان مستويات الميه دي تتقلص بشكل اكبر خلال
الشهور الجايه منسوب الميه في البحيره
دلوقتي بقى قريب من ادنى نقطه تم تسجيلها
على الاطلاق خلال موسم الانطار وبسبب
الطلب المزدوج على مياه البحيره للقناه من
ناحيه ولسكان من ناحيه ثانيه فالبحر
بتواجه عجس مائي قدره 3 مليار لتر يوميا
الرسم اللي قدامنا ده بيوضح منسوب مياه
بحيره جاتون بالادم في واحد يناير 2023
كان منسوب الميه
87.6 قدم فضل منسوب الميه يقل يقل زي ما
احنا شايفين على مدار شهور السنه لحد ما
وصل لادنى نقطه يوم 25 يوليو اللي فات
والمنسوب كان
79.2 ادم بعدها ارتفع حاجه بسيطه لحد يوم
تصوير الحلقه في 21 يناير والمنسوب كان
81.3 ادم طبعا واضح قدامنا فرق منسوب
البحيره في يناير 2023 ويناير 24 مشكله
الجفاف كانت ندره الحدوث في بانما لانها
بتعتبر واحده من اكثر الدول رطوبه في
العالم والبحيرات بتاعتها وبالتالي القناه
طول عمرهم محاطين بوفره في الميه ولكن كل
ده بقى من الماضي والسبب ظاهره الاحتباس
الحراري اللي بتزود حدوث ظاهره مناخيه
معروفه باسم الينو وظاهره النينو بتؤدي
لتعطيل دوران الغلاف الجوي وبالتالي اضعاف
او ازاحه الرياح اللي كان ممكن تجيب المطر
لبنما وغيرها من الدول الاستوائيه
وبالتالي النينو بتجلب ظروف مناخيه ج
وبتتميز بارتفاع درجه حراره المحيط محصله
ده في النهايه امطار قليله جدا وده معناه
ميه قليله في البحيرات وبالتالي بيتم
استنزاف بحيره جاتون بشكل اسرع وكمان
ارتفاع درجات الحراره بيسرع عمليه التبخير
ومع انخفاض منسوب الميه في البحيرات عند
نقطه معينه اضطرت هيئه قناه بانما انها
تاخد تدابير لمنع سفن الحاويات الضخمه
اللي بتشيل لحد 15000 حاويه من الجنوح في
القناه وقرروا تخفيض عمليات المرور
اليوميه من القناه من 38 سفينه في اليوم
لحد 24 سفينه بس في اليوم وممكن الرقم ده
ينزل اكت خلال الشهور الجايه وكمان قللوا
الغاطس بتاع السفن والغاطس هو المسافه بين
اسفل نقطه في بدن السفينه وبين خط الميه
اللي السفينه موجوده فيها قياس الغاطس ده
بيعرفنا كميه الميه اللي السفينه محتاجاها
للابحار بامان من غير ما يحصل جنوح وكل ما
السفينه كانت محمله وضايع ثقيله كل ما
الغاطس بتاعها زاد لانها بتنزل في الميه
بشكل اعمق والعكس صحيح الغاطس التشغيل
الطبيعي بتاع قناه بانما كان
15.24 متر قللو دلوقتي لحد ما وصل ل 13.4
متر بس علشان كده اضطرت شركات الشحن انها
تقلل حموله السفن بتاعتها بنسبه وصلت ل
40% علشان تقدر تعدي من القناه التغير
المناخي ما كانش هو السبب الوحيد في الوضع
الحرج لقناه بناما دلوقتي ولكن التوسعه
اللي عملوها في 2016
و2018 كانت سبب رئيسي ثاني لانهم ركبوا
اقفال جديده ضخمه علشان تستوعب السفن
الضخمه ويزود حركه المرور وفي نفس الوقت
ما عملوش حساب وبانوا خزان جديد لضخ ما
يكفي من المياه العزبه لتشغيل الاقفال
الجديده دي الموضوع بالضبط اشبه بحد عزم
ناس كتيره جدا لحفله عيد ميلاده وفي الاخر
نسي يشتري التورته صرف و مليارات
الدولارات وسعوا القناه ودخلت سفن ضخمه
وباعداد كبيره وانت ما عندكش ميه كفايه
تشغل بها الاقفال الجديده العملاقه دي في
الوقت اللي القناه اصلا لما اتبنت من اكثر
من 100 سنه ما كانتش مصممه انها تتحمل
لانخفاض الشديد في هطول الامتار علشان كده
بدا الزحام عند مداخل ومخارج القناه بسبب
زياده اعداد السفن المنتظره بعض السفن
انتظرت لاكث من اسبوعين واقفه في الميه
على جانبي القنا وده بيزود من مخاطر وقوع
حوادث وتصادم بين السفن قبطان ناقله شايله
غاز طبيعي بيقول للجارديان ان بعض السفن
اضطرت تنتظر في المارسه لمده تصل ل 25 يوم
والسفن بقت على مقربه من بعضها ولو الطقس
كان شديد وفي رياح فهحس تصادم ومزادات
العبور وصلت لارقام خزعبليه في 8 نوفمبر
اللي فات اضطرت مجموعه انيوس اليابانيه
انها تدفع 4 مليون دولار بالاضافه لرسوم
عبور القناه المعتاده واللي وصلت ل
400,000 دولار علشان تسرع مرور احدى
ناقلات غاز البترول المثال البي تي
التابعه ليها واكت سفن بتدفع علشان تعدم
القناه بسرعه هم اللي شايلين نفط وغاز
لانهم لو وصلوا للعميل بتاعهم متاخر
بيدفعوا غرامه كبيره شركات شحن ثانيه مش
مستعجله او مش قادره تدفع المبالغ الضخمه
دي اما بتنتظر في الطابور واما بتكرر تغير
مسار سفنها لقناه السويس قبل ما منطقه
البحر الاحمر تشتعل زي ما وضحنا في حلقه
جحيم فوق الماء واما بتغير المسار وتلف من
جنوب امريكا الجنوبيه عند كيب هورن في
تشيلي واما من طريق راس رجاء الصالح وفي
شركات شحن قررت تفرغ البضايع بتاعتها في
احدى طرفي القناه وتنقلها برا عبر بانما
من خلال القطرات زي ما عملت شركه مارسك
ولكن طبعا جميع الخيارات دي مكلفه وهتاخد
وقت اكبر طب البنامين فكروا في حل المشكله
العويصه اللي بتقابلهم دي الحقيقه جميع
الحلول مكلفه جدا وهتاخد سنين طويله علشان
تتنفذ ولكن ابرز حلين بدا يتم تداولهم
مؤخرا هو اقامه سد على نهر انديو وبعدها
يحفروا نفق في قلب جبل علشان يوصلوا الميه
العازبه لمسافه 8 م م لحد بحيره جاتو بحسب
ايريك كوردوبا مدير قسم المياه في هيئه
قناه بانما
فالتكلفة ست سنين على الاقل وحاليا سلاح
المهندسين في الجيش الامريكي بيعمل دراسه
جدول القصه دي طبعا تنفيذ المشروع ده
هيكون صعب جدا مش علشان التكلفه ولكن بسبب
اعتراض الاف المزارعين مربي الماشيه اللي
اراضيهم هيتم غمرها بالميه واللي بداوا من
دلوقتي ينظموا الصفوف بتاعتهم والحل
الثاني المحتمل واللي لسه بيتم تجريبه هو
تلقيح السحاب في شهر نوفمبر اللي فات وصلت
طياره صغيره تبعه لشركه ويذر فيكيشن
الامريكيه الى بانما لاختبار تلقيح السحب
وتلقيح السحب او استمطار السحب باختصار هو
عمليه زرع جزيئات الملح الكبيره في السحب
لمساعدتها على تساقط الامطار ولكن عمليات
تلقيح السحب بتنجح اكث في المناخات الجافه
مش في البلدان الاستوائيه زي بنما طبعا
شركات الشحن مستقى جدا من الوضع ده لدرجه
ان جيرمي نكسون الرئيس التنفيذي لسادس
اكبر شركه شحن حويات في العالم وهي
العملاقه ياباني اوشان نتورك اكسبريس
والمعروفه اختصارا بوان بعت رساله للرئيس
البنمي لنتين و كوهين طالبه فيها انه
يتحرك بسرعه في مشاريع بنيه تحتيه يزود
بيها امدادات الميه العزبه لقناه بانما
وفي ظل الظروف اللي بتمر بها قناه باناما
دي واللي الله اعلم هتنتهي امتى وازاي ففي
فرصه كبيره لقناه السويس لجذب رحلات
باعداد كبيره كانت بتضطر تمر من قناه
بانما ولكن لازم طبعا تقف الحرب
الاسرائيليه المجرمه على قطاع غزه علشان
الحوثيين يوقفوا استهداف السفن التجاريه
الاسرائيليه اللي بتعدي من البحر الاحمر
ويعود الهدوء من جديد للممر الملاحي الاهم
في العالم بعد ما ده يحصل الاول تقدر قناه
السويس تجذب خطوط الملاحه اللي كانت
متعوده تعدي من قناه بانما لان قناه
السويس عندها مستين مهمين جدا مش موجودين
عند قناه بانما الاولى ان الرسوم بتاعتها
اقل من قناه بانما والثانيه انها بتستوعب
مش بس السفن الضخمه اللي بقت بتعدي من
قناه بانما بدايه من سنه 2016 واللي بتشيل
لحد 15000 حاويه مكافئه ولكن بتستوعب
السفن العملاقه الثانيه اللي بتشيل لحد
21000 حاويه مكافاه مش عاوز اطول عليكم
اكتر من كده وفي النهايه عندي لكم سؤال يا
ريت تجاوبوني عليه في التعليقات تفتكروا
ممكن في يوم من الايام قناه بنا ما تتقفل
بسبب الزواهر المناخيه العنيفه اللي
بيسببها الاحتباس الحراري هتابع كل
اجاباتكم في التعليقات ما تنسوش تشوفوا
رابط شركه ايفي تريد هتلاقوه تحت الفيديو
ويا ريت لو عجبتكم الحلقه تعملوا لايك
وشير للفيديو وتشتركوا في القناه واهم
حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن
يستفيدوا
[موسيقى]
سلام
n